tomtom est venu sans sa soeur nana mais
sa maman bernadette després l'a
accompagné au festival de bande dessinée
de buc le rendez-vous des auteurs et de
leurs héros avec les lecteurs la fille
que vous avez vu qu hélas elle avait 6
ans et elle a tout de suite rentré dans
ses histoires
maintenant elle en a 46 alors je pense
que en effet les parents sont tous un
peu dans cette ligne non et que du coup
il communique un peu ça à leurs enfants
aussi
béatrice qui dessine les tom tom et nana
quand j'étais plus de 6 j'en lisais
beaucoup et là j'ai voulu faire
découvrir mes cousins de rencontrer
rencontrer des personnes dont on
apprécie le travail d'échangé un petit
peu avec eux et bien sûr le dessin la
petite dédicace en bonus et jean a
obtenu la dédicace de jean claude
fournier connu pour avoir dessiné spirou
et fantasio entre les années 70 et 80
j'aime bien rencontrer mes lecteurs
c'est sympa j'aime bien entretenir des
rapports
amicaux avec les gens et puis on
rencontre les copains aussi parce que
bon on est très solitaire on a un métier
très solitaire donc là c'est l'occasion
de rencontrer les copains aussi vrai il
ya des fois au bout d'une centaine de
spirou dans la matinée je commence à
avoir un peu ras-le-bol je propose au
jour d'autres choses mais là c'est le
premier temps à graulhet de son côté
fabien est venu spécialement pour jean
pleyers avec comme demande un portrait
de louis je suis très heureux de le
rencontrer parce que c'est un très grand
dessinateur c'est aussi un très grand
scénariste et puis l'occasion de parler
avec lui de ces projets ou de ce qu'il a
fait durant sa carrière c'est très très
plaisant
au total plus de 8000 visiteurs sont
venus parcourir les vignettes et remplir
les bulles de cette 24e édition du
festival de bd de buc